president Donald Trump's border barrier
is under construction in southern
Arizona wolf crews with heavy equipment
are carving a path through the desert
the wall will go along the southern edge
of the organ pipe cactus National
Monument an area of exceptional beauty
the US National Park Service says the
1340 square kilometer monument preserves
one of the Earth's major ecosystems in
nearly unspoiled condition the United
Nations designated organ pipe National
Monument as an international biosphere
reserve environmentalists say wall
construction threatens this pristine
environment we've got endangered kita
dakedo pupfish also known as the Sonoita
pupfish
right here in this stream you can see
them are they an endangered species they
are I want a for endangered species here
workers will pump water from underground
to mix concrete for the barriers base
possibly drying out this desert oasis
which is just a few hundred meters from
the border the barrier will block the
normal migration routes of rare animal
species like puma and antelope the human
experience will also change a 50
kilometer 9 meter tall wall equipped
with floodlights that are on all night
long that's what's being proposed here
and it's it's insane our night skies are
going to be destroyed we're not gonna be
able to see the stars anymore from the
campground and it's gonna be an eyesore
this is a place that's designated
wilderness it's supposed to look
pristine and now it's going to look like
50 kilometer prison wall in order to
build the wall President Trump declared
a state of national emergency here on
the border now that together with other
legal loopholes has allowed the
government to completely disregard
numerous laws designed to protect
environmentally sensitive areas like
this environmentalists have taken the
administration to court in an effort to
slow or halt construction but for now
the wall
is relentlessly forward rob reynolds al
jazeera near Sonoita mexico